- Why would you do this to us?
- Why?
The Belching Beaver Brewery's
Peanut Butter flavored Milk Stout.
- Cause it's all about the beaver.
- Peanut Butter, that should
be interesting. - Wow, really?
- Molt, oats, lactose, hops,
yeast, and natural flavors.
- It kind of smells like a Reese's Pieces.
- Wow!
- I'm digging it. I'm
digging it. I'm digging it.
- That is peanut buttery.
- I don't know. Is it too early to go
five out of five right out of the gate?
- High Water Brewing Camp Fire Stout.
- Leaves you wanting s'more!
- It evokes fond memories of wilderness
and camping adventures.
- We'll see.
- With graham crackers!
- Wow, this is dark.
- Black.
- Oh yeah. Hell yes.
- It smells like candy.
- Yeah, it smells like candy,
but I know it's not going
to taste like candy.
Hey! This beer would be good for kids!
Don't include that in the video.
- Amazing.
- Yeah, that's really good.
- Oh, no no no no no. No no no no no!
- I'm not getting s'more
out of this at all.
- Out of one out of five?
- One.
- Lemon Chiffon Crueller Ale.
- Sorry, we've already had a couple beers.
- Oh, it's pink!
- Fancy pants.
- Don't mind if I do.
- What's a chiffon?
Lemon chiffon?
- I could not tell you.
- Is it this style of doughnut?
- Maybe.
- I feel like a chiffon's a nice,
like, scarf a lady wears.
- Oh, that looks like dehydrated pee.
- Lemony. Lemon cake.
- It seriously smells like cleaning fluid.
- It does!
- Oh, bleck!
- You don't like it?
- No.
- Oh, I like it.
- A doughnut should be a doughnut,
and a beer should be a beer.
- Banana Bread Beer!
I've heard about this one.
- Yes, I've seen this.
- Bread beer. Look, it says,
"Long ago, ale was known as liquid bread."
- Huh?
- Wow, you know what? It's not even just
banana bread, it's the yellow laffy taffy,
which is my favorite laffy taffy.
- Nope, I don't like it. I don't like it.
- I kind of like it.
- No, it taste like banana candy.
- When you say banana bread beer,
you want some banana bread.
- You want some carbs.
- Yeah, exactly.
- No carbs in here.
- You're right.
- I like it, but...
- I think this could
give you a tummy ache.
- Why flavor something unless
it's better than normal beer?
- You don't do what you claim to be.
- Oh! Double Chocolate!
- This is going to be good as hell.
- It's award winning.
It doesn't say what award it won.
- That's a nice bottle though.
It's like Willy Wonka.
- It's like super dark.
- Ooohkay.
- Oh. Nope.
- You don't like it?
- I don't like it.
- Yes. Yes. No. Mallory's wrong.
- I hate chocolate.
- No. That's so good.
What would you pair it with?
- Turkey leg?
- It's not too chocolaty, though.
- No.
All these big, bragadocious flavors.
Double chocolate? I don't
even taste half chocolate.
Yeah, it smells like off brand chocolate
with a hotel coffee.
- Oh god.
- You know, like hotel coffee? It's free,
and it's in the lobby, but it's not good?
So you like, put a little
of your hot chocolate
packet in to make like,
an impromptu mocha?
But, that's not good either.
But you're tired, so you drink it.